so there are many people who have been
hoping for
waiting for praying for even the demise
of joe biden
and they are really going to have to
keep waiting quite frankly at least for
now
as joe biden's approval rating has
jumped to 63
up two points from late march this is
not about
cheerleading or uh uh
praising when there is nothing to praise
but it is about understanding why joe
biden's approval rating is up again but
also
importantly the areas where it's not
because they actually
are cause for concern and show that the
republican strategy
has actually worked where they have
applied it and we're going to get to all
of that but the data is that a new poll
from the associated press and
norc now has joe biden at
63 percent approval overall
96 approval among democrats trump would
often tout
96 percent approval from republicans we
could never find that data
joe biden really has 96 approval from
democrats ap and orc poll
62 approval from independence and yes a
paltry 23 percent approval among
republicans but that is
dramatically higher than democratic
approval of
trump throughout donald trump's
presidency these are notable
republican approval numbers for how how
high they are even at 23
and overall this puts joe biden at 63
percent approval now
in this poll the number of americans
who are optimistic about the country's
direction is up to 54
we had a different poll yesterday which
had that number
at 40 percent up from 20 this poll
uh asked the question a little
differently and has joe
has uh the country at 54 thinking
we are moving in the right direction
this is the highest of any ap
poll dating back to the beginning of
donald trump's presidency in other words
the country is more optimistic today
than at any time during the trump
presidency
what is pushing joe biden's approval
rating up the issues are
handling of the covid pandemic health
care
and the economy according to this very
same poll
some of this is logical some of it is
more notable for example
democrats tend not to poll as well
on the economy despite the fact that the
economy by every indicator does better
when a democrat is in the white house
rather than a republican that's
interesting
71 percent of americans approve of joe
biden's handling
of the pandemic and we are getting
closer and closer to ending the pandemic
i'm going to have the latest numbers for
you
probably tomorrow maybe thursday the
last week has seen even faster declines
in cases even faster declines in deaths
fortunately an uptick in vaccination and
we will get to that a little bit later
in the week
even 47 percent of republicans approve
of joe biden's handling
of the pandemic 57 percent of americans
approve
of joe biden's handling of the economy
62 percent
approve of joe biden's handling of
health care so far
which has been mostly prioritizing the
affordable care act and a few things
tied in with coveted stimulus not that
much has actually been done yet as far
as health care goes
so consider that disconnect right now
joe biden's approval rating
is high because of his handling of covid
and the economic stimulus and yet zero
republicans not few zero republicans
voted for that very same coveted
stimulus
that is part of why joe biden is popular
even with
a relatively high number of republicans
now on the flip side
joe biden is not at 50 approval on two
major issues
gun policy and immigration
this is super important because these
aren't two issues
on which joe biden has just naturally
struggled to build approval
those two issues gun safety
and immigration are the issues that
republicans have
chosen to attack joe biden over
this means that the republican counter
narratives
the right-wing media counter narratives
do work they do influence
people's thinking and people's opinions
and beliefs almost
from day one i mean not literally day
one i think it was day five
of the biden presidency republicans
and uh peter ducey from fox news and
others started the counter narrative on
immigration the border is chaos
there's kids in cages there's kids
separated from their parents all of the
things
they didn't care about when trump was
president and it has worked
it has worked to build the belief that
there's a crisis on immigration and that
at least to some degree uh it's joe
biden's fault
um there were i think it was back in
june 28
of americans believed there was an
immigration crisis now it's 48
not much has actually changed other than
republicans have been hammering this
issue second issue on which joe biden
is not doing well is gun control biden
has done
almost nothing on gun control understand
that uh after that
recent string of mass shootings joe
biden did announce
he was going to be going after the
government will go after ghost guns a
little more and some
very tame like very very minor gun
safety issues
some of which may not even lead to
anything because they were biden saying
please study this and tell me what to do
so we need to understand that when you
and i
start to see these narratives pop up on
fox news and newsmax and
lindsey graham is talking about it and
whatever we know they're fabricated out
of thin air and we know there's often
nothing to them
but they work and they can be a drag on
presidential approval now
in terms of joe biden's 63 approval
overall
yeah to some degree the american people
are realizing that some things are going
well republicans
have been complaining that joe biden's
tweeting is too boring
and too conventional that's a sign they
don't have much to complain about
we covered that segment on fox news last
week
which i called is the economy doing too
well
under biden and that's when you know
things are going okay economically
and it's pushing joe biden's approval up
beyond where trump ever was during his
presidency remember trump
never achieving 50 approval even once
during his presidency joe biden
was at 61 now at 63.
that's good but we have to understand
that whatever they can get
purchase on traction on and right now
that's guns and immigration
they will use it to try to win in 2022
and we simply have to be ready for it
one of our sponsors is magic
spoon the breakfast cereal that tastes
just like the sugary tasty cereals we
all loved as kids but
without the sugar and without the carbs
magic spoon is sweet and delicious with
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein
and only four net carbs making it
perfect for a low carb
or keto diet and very exciting news
magic spoon has released an awesome new
flavor
birthday cake available for a limited
time only
but you can still get cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter
and cinnamon you can build your own
variety pack our team has tried every
flavor
we've looked at each flavor really
strongly
and we keep asking them to just send us
more you'll get five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the coupon code pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video